in today's video we're going to talk
about 10 tips that you need to know
before
you play animal crossing new horizons
people of the internet retrorec contour
here and welcome back to another animal
crossing new horizons video
these are tips for getting started that
will help new players enjoy some of the
best parts of animal crossing
now let's get into the tips number one
your island name
is permanent one of your very first
tasks in animal crossing will be to name
your island
while there are a number of things and
new horizons you can tweak and change
along the way
your island name isn't one of them so be
sure to brainstorm first and go with
something you'll be happy with for the
long haul
if you plan on using any of the game's
online features such as visiting other
islands
you should know that others will be able
to see the name of your island
so probably best to go with something
that won't embarrass you later on
your island name will appear often and
be referenced in conversation between
you
and other villagers if you're having
trouble you can always look to the
internet for some inspiration there are
even random name generators you can try
i'll throw a link to one of these down
in the description below and as a little
bonus tip here it's also worth noting
you cannot change your name
or birthday either number two you can
change your island layout
eventually in addition to picking your
island name you'll also get to choose
your island's initial
layout pay close attention to the
location of your bodies of water
this will be important for the early
game because you won't have a way to
cross over rivers
or climb cliffs until a bit later in the
game you'll be stuck with this layout
for quite some time but you can change
it once you unlock terraforming which is
the ability to edit your island's cliffs
and bodies of water
but also to add entirely new ones to
unlock this you'll need to get your
island's rating up to at least
3 stars i actually have a video on
getting your island to 5 stars and the
tips are mostly the same for getting to
3 stars
i'll include an interactive card here on
the top right of your screen which you
can click to check out that video
number three pay off your tent early the
beauty of a game like animal crossing is
it doesn't really force you to do
anything there are nudges and hints here
and there but the game lets you go
at your own pace doing what you want to
do one task i do recommend though that
you try and complete quickly
is paying off your tent the game doesn't
really open up until you have a home of
your own to furnish and decorate you'll
actually pay off your tent using nook
miles rather than bells which is the
game's more widely used currency
paying off your tent using nook miles
acts as a tutorial of sorts for
introducing you to the nook mile system
you can use your nook phone at any time
to see what current nook miles
challenges you have
each challenge you complete will earn
you miles the amount varies depending on
the challenge
once you have a house to call your own
you can also use it to store
extra items your first house will have
80 storage slots but by the time you
make the final house upgrade which will
be
well into the game you'll have a
staggering 1600 item slots for storage
number four expand your pockets asap
one of the more frustrating parts of the
early game is just how quickly your
pockets will start
to fill up with items you'll be
delighted to know that you can purchase
two upgrades to expand your pockets
after you've paid off your tent i would
recommend focusing on these two
upgrades you'll need to visit resident
services in the center of town and
access the computer kiosk in the corner
from here you can purchase a pocket
organization guide using nook miles
5000 nook miles may seem expensive but
it's absolutely worth it
the next upgrade will be called ultimate
pocket stuffing and will cost 8 000 nook
miles
again totally worth it trust me after a
few weeks with the game you'll have more
nook miles than you can possibly know
what to do with
unless you want to go on a crazy number
of villager hunts which
i wouldn't blame you if you did after
those two upgrades you'll have four rows
with a total of
40 item slots number five buy a
slingshot
the first chance you get to buy a
slingshot from nook's cranny you should
do it
if you've noticed the floating presence
flying high above your head you should
know that the slingshot is the
only way to retrieve them these presents
may contain
clothing diy recipes furniture or even
30 000 bells
balloons always have a distinct sound
moving through the air as they approach
and you can spot their shadow along the
ground just be careful shooting them
down if it's near a body of water
because it's actually possible to
completely lose out on a present
number six take your time this may seem
like a throwaway tip here but honestly
guys
it could also be the most important one
because as fun and addicting as animal
crossing can be
i truly believe it's an experience best
enjoyed over the course of months rather
than days
some folks choose to time travel by
altering the system clock on the
nintendo switch and if you do that's
entirely up to you
for me personally though i prefer no
time travel whatsoever
it really helps to preserve one of
animal crossings most unique qualities
in that the island truly feels like a
living breathing world
that's continuing on even when you're
not there so prioritize what you want
and go
at your own pace if you want to spend
weeks building a theme park and ignoring
everything else
go for it not that i've done that or
anything all the tutorials online
and videos you see here on youtube this
one included will be here waiting for
you when you're ready to take on
even more challenges number seven find
your money rock
as you start to get to know your island
you'll learn where your rocks are
located
you can have up to six rocks total now
most of your rocks when struck with an
axe or shovel will give you materials
such as stone
iron nuggets or maybe even a gold nugget
on occasion
once per day however one of the rocks
will give you money
instead of materials if you're able to
strike the rock a total of 8
times in rapid succession you'll receive
a total of 16
400 bells now to get that full amount
you can try digging a few holes behind
you to help stabilize your position
in my case here i already have paths
here so instead i have to lay down a few
mannequins
you'll also want to make sure the rock
isn't next to any flowers or other
objects as they would prevent bells from
dropping
in that spot and a little bonus tip here
guys if you accidentally
destroy a rock which you can do by
eating fruit and then hitting the rock
don't worry about losing out on one of
your six rocks because it will actually
reappear the next day
albeit in a completely different
location number eight
money does grow on trees in addition to
a special rock each day you'll also
start to notice spots on your island
that appear to shine or glow
digging in this location will give you 1
000 bells
a nice little surprise of course but if
you want to really maximize these
special locations
you can then replant bells into the same
glowing space
rather than filling the hole back up if
you plan a stack of ten thousand bells
your tree will grow over the next
several days into a special
money tree the tree will triple your
money so if you plant ten thousand bells
you'll receive thirty thousand bells
once the tree fully matures
you can plant less than ten thousand
bells if you prefer but the money that
grows is always based on the original
amount planted
so if you only plant a thousand bells
then you would get three thousand bells
in return
you don't want to go over ten thousand
bells though as the tree will never get
back more than thirty thousand bells
total
number nine learn the crafting system
fairly early in the game tom nook will
introduce you to the game's crafting
system
you'll collect diy recipes from numerous
sources which you can then use at his
crafting table
you can also make your own crafting
tables which can be placed just about
anywhere on your island including inside
your home
crafting is one of the best ways to get
furniture items that fit the overall
theme you're going for both in your home
and on your island even if you don't
necessarily want a specific
craftable item you can always sell them
back to nook's cranny
crafted items almost always earn you
more than selling materials by
themselves
oh and you can also craft fish bait
which is super useful if you're trying
to catch fish
in specific locations if you're new to
animal crossing go ahead and leave me a
comment down below and let me know your
favorite things so far
and if you have any questions about the
early game i'll be happy to answer them
number 10 buy turnips on sundays
if you're looking to become an animal
crossing millionaire several times over
then you'll definitely want to play the
stock market the stock market is animal
crossing
simplified version of our real world
stock market
on sundays between 5 am and 12 pm daisy
may will visit your island offering to
sell you turnips
these turnips range in price but they're
almost always worth buying
i have a full video breaking down all
the secrets about buying and selling
turnips but just to keep things simple
here as long as you don't forget to sell
your turnips
by the next sunday there's plenty of
opportunity throughout the week to sell
them for a great price
either on your own island or by visiting
a friend if you're interested in the
turnip video you'll find it in my animal
crossing beginners playlist which you
should see
on the right side of your screen right
now that's gonna be it for me and
today's video i will talk to you guys
again soon